ist der ein paar sekunden später er hat
vor meiner haustür gekappt hallo mein
name ist luca und meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal und zwar
spiele heute mal wieder sims das ist
luca im bademantel in der letzten folge
sind wir da stehen geblieben dass luca
hier mit der liebe summer holiday auf
der couch sitzt und die beiden schauen
sich keine ahnung was das ist ja auf
jeden fall mega viel spaß hier in lukas
toller 2 zimmer wohnungen
eigentlich brauchen wir immer noch
meinen garten denn meine damen und
herren wofür könnten wir den einen
garten gebrauchen ja ihr seht schon im
titel eingeblendet mein ganzes leben
lang wollte ich schon hund haben meine
eltern meinten nein nein wir hatten
kaninchen und ja die kann ich immer noch
ganz cool aber hat waren halt nicht so
cool wie ein hund von daher finde ich
mir jetzt diesen traum zumindest in sims
das einzige was wir dafür glaube ich
erstmal brauchen ist einerseits geld und
einen computer ich bin aber gerade
ehrlich gesagt zu blöd den computer zu
finden 2000 jahre später nämlich
abstoßen können wir hier einfach mal den
tisch hin und dann können wir jetzt noch
auf den computer klicken und holen uns
dann diese respektablen mittelklasse
computer der kommt dann einfach mal hier
mit ich drauf dann braucht er tut ja
noch ein stuhl da nehmen wir einfach
einen kurs lieblings stuhl den kaufmann
dann haben wir die computer ecke jetzt
auch fertig das heißt luca ich würd mal
sagen du hörst jetzt auf
fernsehzuschauen genau jetzt könnt ihr
nämlich hier draufklicken und
[Musik]
ich stand dass ich damit ein dings holen
kann
klicken sie auf dem pc und dann auf
haushalt und dann steht hier eine
tierklinik kaufen
habt ihr klickt man mal auf adoptieren
dann können wir entweder adoptieren also
wahrscheinlich ein kind ok damit dem
kind warten erstmal noch wir können eine
katze adoptieren und auf einen hohen
dass ich dich jetzt mal auf hund
adoptieren
für 200 kostet das und jetzt
[Musik]
da aber die hunde zwölf verschiedene
hunde stehen zur auswahl
es gibt keinen einzigen golden retriever
ok jollen mit riva ist die absolute
lieblings hunderasse von julia und mir
das sind einfach treue doofe hunde von
daher passt es ganz gut zu unserer oder
später wollen wir uns auf jeden fall ein
golden retriever zulegen
allerdings sind hier jacke oder kann ich
einfach mal aufschließen
das heißt ich klicke jetzt nochmal auf
adoptieren und adoptieren
vielleicht gibt es ja jetzt andere hunde
sind wir noch die gleichen jetzt müssen
wir uns halt verein entscheiden
wir haben hier dickschädel sterilisiert
das heißt die dixie kann auf jeden fall
keine welpen bekommen
das ist einerseits ein bisschen blöd
finde ich und ich meine der name hin hat
mich hier an
also ich meine wiege die kanonen dixie
halten dann haben wir hier den op da
finde ich den namen auch nicht so coole
haben in europa bailey haben wir noch
der ist kastriert wir noch den crash als
auch kastriert mehr noch die sorge die
ist auch sterilisiert den doodle der es
auch stören die cia die diese die sind
alle entweder sterilisiert oder
kastriert tommy haben wir noch den
snacks das ist ein schieber ihn nur dann
haben wir noch den george buckley und
kuba
ich tendiere geradezu cooper der sieht
echt lustig aus ich entscheide mich
jetzt einfach mal für den cooper klicke
jetzt hier auf den haken wir können uns
ja auch noch mehr hunde holen also keine
sorge falls ihr irgendwie die dixie
vielleicht doch kula fandet könnt ihr
was ist das denn
also wir haben jetzt hier eine
hundefreunde das ist der cooper keine
ahnung was für die reiter du kannst auch
gehen ich glaube sogar dass ist ein mann
luca ticker vom guckst fernsehen herr
wir haben gerade hinrunde optiert ich
mache jetzt mal seinen fernseher
bildschirm ihr wegkommen kann es mal
ausmachen
rom hat ein glas hier weg wir haben
besuch luca soll benimm dich mal ein
bisschen erwarten scheiß bademantel an
ich werde meinen bildschirm angerückt um
das anders die gäste rückzugs meine
lieben freunde
luca hat jetzt hier auf jeden fall den
hund bekommen die beiden nähern sich auf
jeden fall luca gibt und die handels
ich bin gespannt was der hund darauf
sich denkt er beschnüffelte auf jeden
fall okay da wir haben auch wieder
pluspunkte bekommen ja wir haben gerade
jetzt geht ja was machst du da jetzt
luca jetzt hör mal bitte auf mit der
scheiße soll jetzt geh mal weg vom
computer ich habe da schon auf das kreuz
gedrückt so gut computer ist aus du
jetzt auf stehen hier zum hund
streicheln luca wir müssen uns ein
bisschen näher kommen wir haben gerade
ein fucking ob dir dich können komplett
ausrasten alter ich freue mich mega okay
der typ geht jetzt schon
[Musik]
muss ich das verstehen es regnet vor
allem komplett draußen hat uns gerade
ein hund vorbei gebracht jetzt läuft
täglich zurück er jobbt auf jeden fall
seine runden
luca geht zum hund okay
er geht zum kühlschrank machst du dem
hund etwas zu as a
der typ ist vom joggen zurückgekommen
was schaut aber was sie sich unterhalten
ist es draußen alter das ist ja wirklich
unfassbar dieses wetter ja so unfassbar
wie deine fresse alter spezi mich auch
jedes mal eine hätte ich am liebsten
cappuccino gerade wenn wir uns weiter
bei deinem visage unterhalten wollen
sandwich das wäre auch gut ja liebe
savages sandwiches und super allerdings
ist der typ jetzt auch wieder abgecheckt
ich habe keine ahnung was seine mission
in dem zusammenhang gerade ist
allerdings würde ich sagen dass wir uns
jetzt mal ein bisschen mit
[Musik]
der hohenzeller kilo khat noch kalt
verlässlich die adoptions bewertung ist
abgeschlossen
bitte was sie können auf das gewünschte
tier klicken oder top 100 ist genau mein
gott ich habe vergessen die darauf da
ich habe verkackt sorry leute was kannst
du eigentlich das heißt wir müssen
nochmal an den pc gehen wir klicken
nochmal auf haushalt adoptieren und hund
adoptieren
das problem gerade war dass ich wohl auf
den hund hätte draufklicken müssen und
dann auf adoptieren hätte klicken müssen
weil man sich erst mal wirklich einen
eindruck von dem hund machen kann das
heißt ich würde sagen wir schauen uns
erst mal den hund noch einmal an ihm das
ding es enthält auch erwachsen
das ist jetzt halt kein welpe ich würde
eher zu einem welpen tendieren weil luca
badoer den scheinverkauf überall rotze
also cooper du bist ganz ganz ganz ganz
heißer runde aber ich glaube luca ist
nicht der geeignete halter für dich eine
ewig gerät später ein neuer tag ist
angebrochen luca guckt seine tv show
sein essen gabelt natürlich was ich rum
soll luca du kommst jetzt erstmal die
ganzen sachen ihr weg genau schön
abwaschen
dann mache ich mal wieder hier auf
normalzeit das heißt ich klicke wieder
wo gehst du denn hin habe ich dir gesagt
hast du ihn wohin gehen darf es ist uns
eine mission ist ja einfach mal eine 40
stellen doch drin rom treten egal also
ich habe keine ahnung was das hier für
ein vollidiot ist er steht immer noch in
der pfütze ich habe keine ahnung was
jetzt sein plan ist jetzt geht er wieder
raus und plötzlich fängt er an zu joggen
sottrum joggt um die pfütze wahnsinn und
denkt wieder an computerspielen genau
der computer ist aber gar keine
schlechte idee luca denn wir müssen ja
gehen nochmal nach den hunden schauen
vielleicht haben ja jetzt ein paar
andere hunde hier am start
ich glaube allerdings nicht weil ich
denke dass simpson er so denkt aber
vielleicht hat er sich verdrückt und der
will den vergleichen und nochmal kaufen
und genau das ist auch der fall wir
haben hier wieder cooper am start wir
haben auch unsere dixi-klo am start ich
würde sagen wir schauen uns mal diesen
krieger an der name ist natürlich jetzt
auch nicht so der allerneueste ich meine
wer seinen hund bitte kritisch
allerdings bin ich von dem echt mal
gespannt
der besitzer ist so ein etwas älterer
geschäftsmann will allein gott ist der
nebel
denn wir haben den muss ich haben warum
ist der scheiß fernseher ihrem weg gehen
juni dort luca jetzt beschäftige dich
doch mal mit diesem hund jahre alter der
ist ja so süß kommen du kannst auf jeden
fall die ich es ist mir ganz egal was er
sagt adoptieren adoptiert brauche ich
dann der so niedlich oh mein gott schaut
ihn euch möchtest du dieses tier
wirklich adoptieren da haben sich um ein
neues tier zu kümmern bringt große
verantwortung mit sich ok
dh wir können den namen sogar noch
umbenennen balu blutdruck schon wieder
berg sehen
du hörst jetzt auf die mit fernsehen
gucken alle möglichen beschäftigt sich
jetzt ein bisschen mit dem hund hier
kommen streicheln gramm tier
es ist ein samstag ich würde sagen wir
haben den hund jetzt erstmal noch das
finde ich auch mal ganz interessant zu
sehen wie luca diesen kleinen hund jetzt
erhebt ihn hoch und ist mein okay das
ist schon süß
willst du den kaffee ballon mein gott
ist das ein süßer nektar eine toilette
muss der kattenvenner kingsley er hat
vor meiner haustür gekappt und jetzt
klug
der zweite teil dieser bisherigen sims
serie ist das ja gerade das ziel heute
war das für ein gott der hat gerade den
rot mit der kühlschranktür geschlagen
das ziel heute war auf jeden fall dass
wir uns einen kleinen hund adoptieren
und ich glaube das haben wir ja jetzt
echt also der ist echt mega süß ich
glaube das haben wir wirklich
erfolgreich gemeistert heute wie die
ganze story hier in sims mit luca und
balu weitergeht erfahrt ihr dann nächste
woche im nächsten paar tipps wenn ihr da
überhaupt bock drauf habe last ein like
bei diesem video hier dauert bei 50.000
likes meine lieben freunde ich weiß eine
große zahl aber das zeigt mir helga bock
auf sims ihr wollt nächste woche neuen
part und ihr wollt sehen wie ich mit
balu weiter ja keine ahnung was ich da
mit dem mache können wir auch in die
kommentare schreiben
[Musik]